it's election time in Burundi the
country's still suffering from the
crisis caused by the last one five years
ago campaigns have begun ahead of next
month's vote for the president and
members of parliament amid a Quran a
virus outbreak there's no social
distancing this rally of the ruling
party rights groups say there's not much
room for other views because the ruling
parties used fear and repression against
political opposition president pierre
and currents either sitting on the right
has ruled Burundi for 15 years he's now
backing one of his closest allies ever
east and Dashami a sitting next to him
as his successor who was unconscious
decision to run for a controversial
third term five years ago that plunged
the country into turmoil the opposition
said it was against the Constitution and
took to the street protests were
violently broken up by police detentions
disappearances and killings of activists
and government critics have been
reported regularly ever since the
opposition boycotted the polls on
Corrine's Issa was declared the winner
but this time opposition parties are
running that this rally supporters of
presidential candidates
Agathon Raza gathered to hear him speak
his party says more than 200 of its
members have been imprisoned and
supporters are often beaten by the
ruling party's militia where our people
are attacked and there is no judiciary
or police prostitution which could could
be conducted against the perpetrators
the opposition rallies again no keeping
distance coronavirus cases are on the
rise Burundi hasn't enforced a lockdown
like some of its neighbors health
experts say it could be a creeping
disaster
the Electoral Commission says it's
taking precautions affecting us is that
in preocupes you're actually the
coronavirus is a concern in Burundi and
we've been in touch with the Health
Ministry who have responded positively
to provide kits and other means to
protect ourselves during and after the
elections the ruling party spared no
expense on t-shirts flags and caps few
people believe this election is a
process that could result in it leaving
power many are concerned there'll be
more rights abuses and violence along
the way
Malcolm Webb al-jazeera